thank you
well guys
it didn't happen
Somewhere Out There
Matt Ramos AKA soups is ready to
Massacre all of San Diego
let's go
laughs
I'll be honest
um I I actually I did expect at this
time you know
so for the longest time we've been
hearing you know the all rumors for
years Henry Cavill is going to return as
Superman Henry Cavill is going to return
and I almost didn't even do a video
about it but then when I was looking
into it I was like this actually seems
likely this time and a lot of people
really believed it you know and to me it
extends far past whatever your opinion
is of the Snyder verse it like some
people just really want it and some
people hate it and wanted to die it's
not even about the Snyder verse although
you know when that when it started going
around that report a couple days ago
Zack Snyder posted a photo of him and uh
Henry Cavill so I was like this seems
like it's really going to happen and
then I you know I heard that he's
actually in London uh filming Witcher
then I mentioned it in the in the video
I did the following day but you know no
one's like watching that video to get my
little update on that I honestly think
it's not Warner Brothers responsibility
necessarily
to
clarify and let people know guys look
it's really not gonna happen because
even if they said that
and if people came back like they're
just lying to try to surprise us they
would have Warner Brothers would at
least get the benefit of the doubt and
the credit for going okay we just didn't
believe them but they were they were
actually telling the truth you know what
I mean so yeah
Andrew did you believe it what do you
think I mean I was hoping I was hopeful
and uh I guess you like you like Henry
Cavill I love Henry Cavill with Superman
I mean it's I mean Christopher Reeve is
always going to be the gold standard for
superman but Henry Cavill he's he's
fantastic I mean I I've looked all the
the different interpretations we've
gotten of Superman from Brandon Routh
and uh Tyler however you say his last
how did you say his last name hodgepodge
yeah there you go exactly I mean I I
like I like all the different
interpretations we give Superman but
Henry Cavill I loved Man of Steel I like
the ultimate edition of Batman v
Superman I like the Snyder cut of
Justice League
um I just feel like you know he hasn't
gotten a fair Shake though from you know
from a perspective of Superman's
storyline and I really feel like he
deserves a chance to have Man of Steel
too I mean we still have hope that you
know the announcement of one at some
point is gonna happen the multiple panel
later today we're actually joking about
they're like can you imagine if Henry
Cavill actually came in with announced
to be in a Marvel filming sorry I'm late
yeah exactly so whoops wrong wrong
Universe my bad but I mean I mean I did
know that he was filming Witcher season
three but I mean I thought maybe they
were gonna do like a video thing just
him just like right you know come off
and say hey guys just letting you know
you know I don't know Zack Snyder's not
coming back but I'm gonna be back uh
we're gonna make another Man of Steel
film so I mean I was hoping for that but
we still could have that I'm still
holding out hope I mean because I I
really want this man to yeah I really
exactly I really want this man to to get
another shot at playing Superman because
I mean he really defines you know the uh
this role and I just love what he does
with the character and I really want him
to get that chance to get that right
storyline that he deserves and and the
proper uh if he's gonna uh you know get
a send off at least get another film uh
under his belt yeah yeah I mean I really
do think that Warner Brothers could
easily see that the most talked about
anticipated thing out of sdcc that
people were hearing Rumblings about or
else it's not a verse whatever you think
was Henry Cavill will appear so they I
really think they shouldn't be leaving
their Lasting Impression with the online
discussion about like they have to know
that there's going to be disappointment
with that if they don't want to bring
them back they don't want to bring him
back I still stand by they should have
said something Johnny I feel like they
they should have I mean to me this could
have always gone either way today I
wasn't really a hundred percent
believing one side or the other and and
the more this goes the more it feels
like they are holding on to a card like
I don't know if Henry Cavill will
actually get to Don the cape again but I
feel like with all the trouble they've
had with all of their casting pretty
much in some regard I feel like they are
probably
watching what happens with the new wave
of movies that they have coming out plus
what the ultimate outcome will be with
flash and I feel like they could be
tucking that card away for the right
Opera opportune time to announce a
return of Henry Cavill Cavill as
Superman in order to bring back good
will when some of these really heavy
pieces finally come to fall I think they
don't want to necessarily distract from
Black Adam and Shazam 2 with Superman
but they also have the flash to very
much worry about and yeah I mean they
have it out and out said he's out and
there's new management so I feel like
people definitely know the value of the
conversation around him and the love
that people have for his portrayal
there's definitely a shared perspective
that he hasn't gotten to really fully
embody the character in a way that
really shows his full ability to shine
in that role and so I I have a
confidence that it might still actually
happen down the road but I'm not
actually surprised it didn't happen
today yeah like there's rumors about and
then like it's nothing's confirmed but
there's rumors of a Superman cameo in
Black Adam but the rumor goes that it's
like how the other Superman cameos have
been of you know uh like how Peacemaker
did it and how Shazam did it were you
don't see his face it's just the image
of Superman but obscured in some way and
they show everyone else's face and that
feels it starts to feel more and more
intentional as they do that and so when
it comes to
um Henry Cavill
you know Dwayne Johnson he's been pretty
much putting it out there I want Henry
Cavill back like he I feel like he's
made that pretty clear that he's made it
clear he wants to fight Superman and him
and Henry Cavill have gone back and
forth online about it and so perhaps you
know you're right about that of if you
know let's say black maybe more than the
flash maybe if Black Adam does really
well and people really respond to that
and then the rock being the rock holding
the rock power might be like all right
we did it now I want my Superman you
know I feel like he's more interested
and I think you know would you I feel
like you'd want to see Black Adam versus
Superman more than you would want to see
black animals for sure I mean uh I I
recently also just rewatched that uh
that animated uh you know Superman
Shazam versus Black Adam that 15 minute
one yeah yeah the third one right yeah
yeah and uh with Arnold vuselu as uh the
voice of Black Adam and I mean yeah just
watching that in animated form like oh
my God I want to see this so bad in live
action form especially with Dwayne
Johnson's uh Black Adam as well as Henry
Cavill Superman I mean that would be
that'd be epic Beyond epic in my opinion
yeah I honestly think that them's asking
directly at the panel who would win in a
fight between you and Superman and him
saying it depends on who's playing him I
feel like that is the Henry Cavill
appearance if if there is one I feel
like that's a hint if anything and it
also doesn't hurt that The Rock's
ex-wife represents both him and Henry
Cavill that's also a good thing and
she's sleeping with Henry Cavill
and the rock yeah it's been doing it
wrong it's a triangle now well guys
why don't you send a loving message to
soups let him know let him down easy let
him know like let's move forward let's
go forward
uh yeah well
hey what are you gonna do
just keep holding out hope I guess
thanks for being here and um yeah we'll
talk with you soon
[Music]